Okay. Guten Abend. Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Usluoghulari. Ich bin auf dieser Station als
Assistenzartistik, würde mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch führen.
Wenn Sie damit einverstanden? Ja Doktor, sehr gerne. Ja und so erst möchte ich die
personische Frage stellen. Wie heißen Sie? Mein Name ist Olaf Thon. Könntest
Sie bitte Ihre Vornachnahme bestabieren? Ja Vorname ist Olaf mit O-L-A-F und
Nachname ist Thon. Ja Herr Thon, wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 30 Jahre alt geworden jetzt.
Und wann ist sie genau geworden? 22. Januar 92.
Und wie groß sind Sie? Ungefähr 1,80 m. Und wie viel wiegen Sie? 70 kg. Ja Herr Thon, was
ist sie zu uns? Ja Doktor, ich habe schon wieder Schmerzen im Herzbereich, in der Brust,
die auch in den linken Armen ausstrahlen und habe dann auch so richtig Todesangst. Und mein Herz rast,
habe auch Luftnot und viele Probleme noch. Deswegen komme ich zu Ihnen. Ja Herr Thon,
haben Sie gestärkt Schmerzen? Jetzt habe ich auch Schmerzen. Haben Sie dagegen eine Tablette
eingenommen? Nein Herr Doktor, ich habe jetzt keine Tablete eingenommen. Es hilft auch nicht
so viel. Ich habe das jetzt schon ein paar Mal gehabt, das muss ich auch dazu sagen.
Und deswegen bin ich jetzt nochmal zu Ihnen gekommen. Ja. Und können Sie diese Schmerzen,
oder wir können kurz unterbrechen und ich würde gerne eine EKG in den Schreiben. Okay. Und danach
könnten wir wieder weitergehen. Okay. EKG ist geschrieben, normal befunden, machen wir
weiter. Okay. Auch Kadiak Enzym soll um die Jahre. Das ist noch nicht da. Wir müssen
noch warten, aber Sie führen schon mal das Gespräch. Okay, danke. Und das ist gut. Und seit
wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen? Seit heute Morgen. Und ja, jetzt bin ich zu Ihnen gekommen.
Aber ich war schon jetzt noch mehrfach wegen dieser Probleme, habe einen Krankenhaus gewesen
jetzt. Heute Morgen. Und haben Sie auch Luftnot? Ich habe auch so das Gefühl, dass mein Mund
so ein bisschen taub wird drumherum. Ich habe Kopfschmerzen, mein Kopf dreht sich,
ich zittere. Also Probleme, die ich jetzt auch wieder habe. Schon wieder habe.
Haben Sie bemerkt, haben Sie im Morgen ein ungewöhnliches Ding erlebt? Nein, war das normal.
Es kam ganz plötzlich. Eine stressige Station. Kann ich nicht sagen, Herr Doktor, nein.
Ich war schon mal deswegen im Krankenhaus. Da war vielleicht Ihr Kollege da. Ich weiß
nicht. Das war vor drei Wochen natürlich gleiche Probleme gehabt. Und das ist schon das sechste
Mal, wo ich jetzt in den Krankenhaus gehe mit den gleichen Beschwerden. Und ich habe auch
schon, weil die nicht genau wussten, und Herzkatheter schon bekommen. Haben Sie ein Herzkatheter
bekommen? Ja, habe ich Herzkatheter bekommen auch. Und? War nichts zu sehen.
Weil keine, keine Befundung. Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden,
sechsmal, sie haben sechsmal Krankenhaus? Ungefähr ein bis zwei Jahre schon fast.
Was denken Sie, gibt es ein bestimmtes Auslösen für diese Schmerzen oder für diese Beschwerden?
Ich habe nichts herausgefunden. Also ich habe auch eine Gastritis gehabt.
Weswegen ich auch Medikamente einnehme, aber auch danach, nach diesem Tabletten ist es auch nicht besser geworden.
Nicht besser geworden nach der Tabletto? Nicht besser geworden.
Irgendes kommt vom Herzen. Man muss nur richtig gucken, glaube ich.
Ja, ja. Ich würde gern alles gucken. Herr Doktor, wie ich nicht Sorge machen.
Und haben Sie auch Hüsten? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Oder Fieber? Auch nicht, nein.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig? Ja, Schwindel ist mir jetzt auch.
Können Sie beschreiben, Ihre Schwindel? Ihr Schwindel ist genau wie mit einem Karuser oder im Schiff?
Ich würde sagen, wie im Karuser.
Seit wann haben Sie Schwindel?
Auch seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe, seit morgen.
Ja, seit morgen.
Sie haben erwähnt, dass es auf den Arm oder in den Beinen gefühlt ist.
Kann ich nur nicht sagen, nein.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ich habe auch schlechter geworden, ich habe auch Probleme mit der Verdauung.
Ein Durchfall, dann habe ich eine Woche lang keinen Stuhl gegangen.
Es ist sehr unterschiedlich auch, dass die Mr. Appetit auch nicht so gut ist.
Ihr habt ihr Verständnis, ihr habt manchmal Guts, manchmal Verstopfung.
Ein Durchfall heißt, da ist kein Wasser, aber es ist dünner als sonst.
Dann habe ich fast eine Woche lang keinen Stuhl gegangen.
Es ist sehr unregelmäßig, mit der Verdauung.
Haben Sie in der Liste seit Apotes zu Genom?
Ungefähr gleich.
Haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Nein.
Haben Sie für Erkrankungen?
Also, haben Sie Gastritis?
Das ist ein Erlebnis.
Haben Sie dafür eine Magenspügelung durchführt gelassen?
Ja.
Und wissen Sie Ergebnisse?
Sie haben gesagt Gastritis.
Das ist nur Gastritis.
Leiden Sie an der Konünsche Krankheiten?
Nein, keine Krankheiten.
Sie haben erwähnt, sie nehmen Gastritis Tableten.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig?
Fast.
Wenn ich nicht immer Beschwerden habe, nehme ich sie.
Wie viele Milligramm?
40 Milligramm.
Nehmen Sie andere Medikamente ein?
Gehen Sie nicht in die Musik?
Nein.
Wurden Sie schon operiert?
Haben Sie Allergie?
Nein.
Haben Sie Unverträglichkeit gegen ein bestimmtes Medikament?
Rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Haben Sie geraucht?
Sie haben Erkrankungen?
Nein.
Haben Sie schon Drogen probiert?
Sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Mein Vater ist leider gestorben.
Er war auch noch jung.
Es war plötzlich ein Herzdot.
Er war weiter auf der Arbeit.
Er war nie krank gewesen.
Er war immer gesund.
Er war noch nicht mehr stehen geblieben.
Wie war er alt?
Er war nicht so alt.
Er war Anfang 50.
Wann ist Ihre Vater gestorben?
Da war ich ungefähr 15 Jahre.
Wie war er alt?
Anfang 50.
Er war 52 oder 53.
Er war nicht mehr genau erinnern.
Ist Ihre Mutter gesund?
Sie hat Diabetes.
Sie hat Schilddröten unter Funktion.
Sie hat Arthrose.
Sie hat Schilddröten.
Die Types sind für Diabetes.
Die Types sind für WI.
Haben Sie ein Schwester?
Ja.
Sie sind gesund.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein.
Wir wollten beheiratet.
funktioniert und dann sind wir getrennt.
Und waren Sie getrennt?
Ja, das ist auch schon so fast zwei Jahre jetzt.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Und was ist Ihr Beruf?
Ich bin Sachbearbeiter im Finanzamt.
Und waren Sie schon in Ausland?
Ja, aber es ist schon lange her jetzt, fünf Jahre.
Und wurden Sie gegen Corona vollständig geimpft?
Ja, bin ich vollständig. Ich habe auch die dritte Impfung schon bekommen.
Haben Sie Sorgen für die Zukunft oder für die Leben?
Oder haben Sie Gedanken?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das jeder hat, so wie jeder Mensch, glaube ich.
Und können Sie gut schlafen?
Mir ist so gut, nein.
Ich stehe oft auf, nachts.
Man kann auch oft nicht gut einschlafen.
Ich bin schon in der Zeit, wenn ich nicht mehr schlafe, ist es nicht gut.
Waren Sie schon, oder sind Sie beim Haus oder bei den Kardiologen gewesen?
Ich glaube, Sie haben erwähnt.
Ja, im Haus hat es schon mehrfach.
Und er hat mich auch schon mehrfach ins Krankenhaus geschickt.
Aber bisher ist nichts gefunden worden.
Dann haben Sie nur Hausarzt und Krankenhausbesuch?
Haben Sie andere Facharztes besucht?
Nein, nur Hausarzt und Krankenhaus.
Ja, Herr Ton, ich habe alle wichtigen Fragen gestartet.
Wollen Sie auch nochmal eine Laborwerte nochmal haben, die mein Haus abgenommen hat?
Soll ich das auch nochmal geben, damit Sie auch nochmal alles genau kontrollieren können?
Ja, aber ich würde gerne auch Körperlisch untersuchen.
Ich habe auch eine weitere Erklärung.
Ich werde hier auch eine Diagnostik aufnehmen.
Was haben Sie geplant, Herr Doktor?
Ich werde hier noch eine Laborabnahme machen.
Aber ich werde eine Laborabnahme machen,
die im Körneren im
Körneren, der Hormone, und das Blutbild,
natürlich auch Herzinsümen wiederkontrollieren.
Haben Sie auch Kulesterine, Doktor? Das wäre mir wichtig, wenn man noch mal Kulesterine guckt.
Natürlich, ja, natürlich.
Wir haben auch Langzeit-EKG durchgefühlt.
Okay, sehr gut.
Ich mache alles, was Sie sagen.
Okay, danke schön.
Aber wir sollen auch andere Ursache denken.
Wenn wir alle die Diatristen, die wir machen,
und sie nicht eine bestimmte Ursache finden,
es kann sein, wir können wieder besprechen.
Okay, alles klar.
Aber ich glaube, man wird was finden,
wenn man genau sucht, damit man bestimmt was finden, glaube ich.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe.
Okay, gut.
Gehen Sie fertig, Herr Doktor?
Ja, fertig.
Gibt es Fragen von den Kommentaren?
Haben Sie Husten?
Hat gefragt, hat keinen Husten?
Welche Untersuchungen wurden früher durchgeführt?
Sie haben gesagt, dass sie weniger in Nacht geschlafen.
Was stört sich?
Vielleicht haben Sie eine Rauchschmerzen oder Herzschmerzen?
Also nicht wegen Schmerzen nachts.
Das hat andere, also unabhängig von den Schmerzen.
Er kann einfach nicht anschlafen, dann macht er oft auf, aber nicht wegen Schmerzen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Keine Probleme beim Wasserlassen, nein.
Atemnot hat er gesagt, hat auch Atemnot, Luftnot.
Atemabhängige Teugerschmerzen.
Wenn Sie fragen, tut es weh, wenn Sie tief einatmen?
Nein, hat er nichts dazu zu sagen.
Das ist immer gleich der Schmerz.
Sonstige Fragen oder Kommentare?
Hatten Sie einen Unfall?
Noch mal bitte.
Kein Unfall.
Wie viele Etagen können Sie hochgehen?
Normalerweise kann ein 3-4 Stockwerke hochlaufen.
Geschwollene Beine, das ist eine gute Frage auch.
Hat er nicht? Nein.
Was haben Sie an der Zahnoperation gehabt?
Eigentlich nicht, warum fragen Sie?
Sie legen sich auf den Rücken und schlafen.
Kann er, ja.
Kann flach liegen, ja.
Hatten Sie schon einmal einen Angstanfall?
Mit starke Angst?
Vielleicht mit Unruhe?
So wie jetzt, ja.
Das hat schon mehr Fad dieser Herzschmerzen, mit Angst, Todesangst gehabt.
Sechs, sieben Mal, glaube ich, gesagt.
Wo sie in eine Koloskopie durchgeführt, ja, das Koloskopie ist auch gemacht worden, ja.
Alles.
Aber ohne patologischen Befund.
Sie haben keine Frage.
Sind Sie schmerzhaft?
Sehr gute Frage.
Sie fragen nach Belastungsabhängigschmerzen.
Nein, die Schmerzen sind unabhängig von Belastung, ja.
Sind Sie schmerzhaft?
Nichts, habe ich schon gefragt.
Unabhängig.
Atemunabhängig und Belastungsunabhängigschmerzen, ja.
Das ist eine wichtige Frage, ja.
Mit dem Essen oder Nahrungsaufnahme?
Hat er nicht so richtig beobachtet, ja.
Herzrasen, hat er seinen Herz klopft, ja.
Also hat vermutlich schon Herzrasen oder Tachikadie.
Gut.
Weitere Kommentare.
Wir haben ganz viele Kommentare noch hier bekommen.
Haben Sie schon einmal ein Bewusstsein verloren?
Nein.
Ich habe schon ziemlich viele Fragen, aber ich glaube,
es war sowieso schon die anderen Mäser komplett.
Was ist Ihre Verdacht, Herr Doktor?
Ja, meine Frau, ich habe eine Verdacht.
Ich kann es sein.
Ich habe keine Frage.
Ja, klar.
Deswegen haben Sie gut gemacht,
dass Sie den Patienten, den Sie nicht kennen,
haben Sie gleich eine Kage geschrieben.
Das war schon mal sehr gut.
Wenn Sie ihn kennen, haben Sie es nicht gemacht.
Aber die Art de fernsehär Diagnosen kommen.
Panik.
Anginapakteur, der Herzenfakt, das ist die wichtigste.
Art de fernsehär Diagnosen.
Und die Art de fernsehär Diagnosen kommen.
Perikadeetis.
Gastriktis oder Gastroeserreflu,
oder Panikattacken,
Perikadeetis, Konezstein,
auch Art.
Art und Direktion.
Nein, nein.
Kann sein, aber...
Und dann noch mal Traxis.
Ich habe gerade gerade eine Frage.
Was ist Ihre Diagnose in seinem Fall?
Sie haben ja schon viele Sachen gefragt.
Sie haben ja auch angegeben,
was Sie schon mal diese Beschwerden hatte.
Rethlokrankeit, Konezstein.
Das sind die Differenzialdiagnose.
Was ist Ihre Hauptdiagnose bei den Patienten?
Oder sagen Sie, Sie stellen die Hauptdiagnose erst,
nachdem Sie die Untersuchung gemacht haben?
Ich muss alle, wenn ich alle zum Verschilus könne,
kann ich etwas sagen.
Aber kann ich Panikattacken,
der passiert ist,
Junggepassiert, 30 Jahre alt.
Hat kann Risikofaktoren?
Ja, Risikofaktoren,
sei mit Vata, sei an myocardiumfacilus,
verspürt.
Meistens mal.
Aber es ist nicht...
Ich kann die Patienten vorstellen.
Was können Sie?
Ich möchte Ihnen die Patienten vorstellen.
Dann stellen Sie mal vor, dann machen wir die Nachteiddiagnose.
Nachteiddiagnose.
Herr Oberar, Sie haben gesagt,
Sie haben einen Patienten vorstellen.
Ja, Herr Olafton,
er ist 30 Jahre alt.
Er ist ein Meter,
80 cm groß
und 70 kg schwer.
Der Patient, der Patient,
der Patient, der sich bei uns wegen
heute Morgen aufgetreten hat,
hat eine Bechtehene
Angina pectoris 4.
Der Patient
die Schmerzen
strahlen
in den linken Arm, in den Tiefen,
unter den Tiefen, in den Schultern aus.
Und der Patient klagt
über Sephargie, Dispene,
und Todesangst.
Und Top-Heist.
Der Patient, außerhalb der Patient
berichtete, dass er
seit einem Jahr
gleiche Becher werden
sechsmal nach der Krankenhaus besucht.
Oder gekommen sein.
Und
der Patient habe
wegen dieser Beschwerden
ein Herzkatheter durchführen gelassen.
Aber er gibt,
es sei unauffällig.
Es sei unauffällig.
Der Patient klagt über auch
Schwindelik.
Er habe
Direktschwinden.
Aber gleichzeitig dieser Beschwerden.
Der Patient
habe im
Wechsel
eine Becherung
im Wechsel
und Verstoffung.
Und sein Appetit ist
gut.
Und der Patient
der Gewicht
sei konstant.
Und der Patient
habe leider an Gastritis
und er nehme
regelmäßig Pantopysol 40 mg
einmal täglich. Dafür habe er
einen Undyscopy durchführen gelassen.
Und der Befund sei gastritis.
Der Patient
sei bisher keine OP
nicht operiert worden.
Ja.
Und er habe keine
Allergie.
Er ist nicht raucherin. Er hat
ALKOLKONSUM und DROHGENKONSUM
verneint.
Er leidete sein Vater an
Mio-Kardinfarktös.
Seine Mutter leidete an
Typs 2, Diabetes Melutus
und Kokos Arthrose. Aber der Patient hat die typische Diabetesmenüs in den Scheren.
Der Patient hat zwei Geschwister, sie ist ein Gesund, er sei getrennt fast
und hat eine Erhabe, die ich in der Erzache arbeite, in der Finanzamt.
Und ja, die Anamnestischen Erhabe, die ich in der Erhästung habe,
Angina pectoris Hing.
As differential diognosen common gastritis.
Gastroesatage refluxrankheit.
Pericarditis und Panikattacken in Betracht.
Das ist ein weiterer Erklag.
Hier ist die folgende Diagnostische Masame.
Die folgende Diagnostische Masame ist die Musikkörperliche Unterrichtung.
Die Laborabnahme ist die Musikmache.
In der Laborabnahme ist die Tropokardiac Enzyme.
Traponin T.
CKMB.
Sündeparameter.
Blutbild.
Chrypteris und Hormone.
Auch Leberfunktionen, Niedrungfunktionen, bestimmen.
Und EKG schreiben.
Ich habe das gemacht.
Da geh' ich, weil haben Sie gemacht, das war ja unabhängig.
Es sei unabhängig.
Die erste Welt war auch unabhängig.
Ja, unabhängig, aber ich muss wieder machen.
Und ich muss den Patient auf die Station aufnehmen.
Und ich würde den Patient beobachten.
Und sechs Stunden später würde ich wieder troponente bestimmen.
Und wenn das normal ist, was machen Sie dann wieder mit den Patienten?
Wir haben Bettennot, Sie wissen.
Wir haben keine Betten auf Station.
Mit der Nochmal?
Wir haben Bettennot, wir haben keine Betten auf Station.
Ja, wegen Corona haben wir ja nicht viel Betten.
Ja, was machen Sie?
Sechs Stunden später.
Und gleichzeitig würde ich Echo durchführen.
Ja, okay.
Wenn alles normal ist, was machen Sie dann?
Ja, dann sollte ich ein psychischer Konsul durchführen.
Das dauert zwei Tage, bis der Psychiater kommt.
Dann eine Ambulanz, Termin Terambare-Ich.
Also lassen wir den Patienten nach Hause wieder, oder?
Wenn alles in Ordnung ist.
Ja, kann der Patient zu Hause gehen.
Ja, okay.
Was machen Sie?
Ich kann den Patienten einige Berungsmittel, SSRA oder Sektralin oder
irgendwelche Berlungsmittel brauchen.
Ja, der Patient hat ja nichts am Herzen, oder?
Er hat schon 6-mal EKG-Proponieren gemacht.
Alles wurde gemacht.
Was ist das für ein Typ von Patienten?
Können Sie mal beschreiben?
Panikattacken.
Also richtig Panikattacken hat er ja nicht gehabt.
Aber das, was er beschrieben hat, können damit zusammenhängen.
Aber wie würden Sie den Beschreiben charakterisieren?
Ja, ich finde, ist der locker?
Nein, nein, der ist langsamer.
Das ist der langsamer.
Der Patient hat Verdammtprobleme.
Und der Problem ist, dass er mich im Ritual-Kolon hat.
Er hat mir gesagt, Reistarm-Sendrom,
oder Reistarm-Sendrom, HBR.
Und wir können diese Sendrom mit Panikattacken
oder psychischen Probleme Patienten.
Das ist himmelsauf die Panikattacken.
Oder psychische Probleme.
Aber ich habe mir gesagt,
Was schreibt das Diagnose auf?
Er hat ja keine Angedapakteur.
Er ist ja nicht die Diagnose.
Er hat keine belastungsabhängen Schmerzen.
Er hat keine stabilen Angedapateur.
Er hat keine Herz- und Zimik-Aggen.
Aber muss ich so erst die Angedapakteur auszuschließen?
Er war vor vier Wochen in Gleichen Beschwerden.
Er hat Langsamer-Aggen bekommen.
Langsamer-Produkt-Messung.
Was machen Sie jetzt mit ihm?
Was ist der Diagnose?
Angedapakteur.
Panikattacken.
Panikattacken, okay.
Panikattacken aufs Herz bezogen.
Wie nennt man das?
Kennen Sie den Begriff dafür?
Ich kenne.
Aber ich kann nicht erinnern.
Kann ich nicht erinnern?
Nein, nein.
Aber er hat es schon beschwerden.
Was ist Monika?
Ich weiß nicht, was Monika ist.
Der Patient hat Sintrom der funktionellen Herzbeschwerden.
Oder Dacostasyndrom.
Dacostasyndrom.
Hat sogar seinen eigenen Namen.
Herzneurose oder Herzphobia.
Das ist seine Diagnose.
Aber klar, Sie können nicht immer abtun.
Aber wenn der Patient schon mehr hat,
dann kann er den gleichen Beschwören alles schon gemacht.
Da können Sie nicht mehr von Neumann fangen.
Deswegen würden Sie den als Herzneurotika abstempeln.
Aber psychotherapie ist wichtig.
Brühungsmittel sind wichtig für den Patienten.
Also Tranquileiser.
Und sonst auch,
dass man den psychosomatisch behandelt.
Ich hatte Kontrollzwang.
Er hat das Gefühl, dass er alles kontrollieren muss.
Das war die Frage nach dem Typ.
Er befolgt alles ganz genau.
Er hat dadurch auch, wie sagt man,
einen sekundären Krankheitsgewinn.
Er hat eine Daseinsberechtigung.
Er kann seine Probleme alle auf diese Herzprobleme zurückführen.
Er hat als Jugendliche sein Vater verwendet.
Er hat eine Daseinsberechtigung.
Magazine hat eine Daseinsberechtigung.
Ok, jetzt bin ich auch auf dem Board.
Ich kann dir meine Autumnm inputschauen.
Ich habe meine Autumnmitsch bracketen.
Das ist auch eine DH.
Kommentarer zu dem Fall oder also was sie natürlich nicht machen dürfen ist gleich wenn der Patient den sie nicht kennen mit
mit erst mal diese Beschwerden kommen, können sie nicht sagen gleich da kostet ein Ruhm, ja.
Das darf ein Set durch bei der Prüfung, ja. Aber der war schon mehrfach da deswegen.
Also funktionelle Herzbeschwerden kann man auch sagen. Also Herzja-Beschwerden, aber man kann gar nicht eine Ursache finden dafür, ja.
Das muss man so sagen.
Okay. Kommentarer zu dem Fall oder Fragen.
Wenn nicht, dann würde ich sagen gehen wir zum zweiten Fall, ja.
Okay, vielen Dank. Danke schön.
Kinci, komm mal los.
Ich halte es, aber ich werde es für mich erst mal aufheben.
Insşallah.
Ich kann es.
Was schlimmer.
Siehst du, mein Name, ich bin Dienstherrbein der Arztin auf dieser Station und würde gerne das Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Sie sind dann verstanden?
Ja.
Ja gut, ich würde am Anfang ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Mario Basler.
Mario?
Mario.
Und nachnamens Basler.
Basler.
Ja Herr Basler, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 24 Jahre alt.
24 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,80 m und 75 kg.
75 kg.
So Herr Basler, was können Sie tun?
Herr Doktor, ich komme mit dem folgenden Problem.
Ich habe also letzte Woche was gewesen.
Donnerstag, also knapp eine Woche ist es her, hat sich ganz starke Halsschmerzen auf Fieber gehabt.
Und meine Hals war auch richtig geschwollt und musste auch wirklich Schmerzmedikamante einnehmen.
Und dann war ich dann auch nochmal beim Hausarzt gewesen.
Und der hat mir dann auch, weil der Hals ein bisschen geschwollt war, auch Lymphknoten, hat er gesagt, hat er sich geworden.
Hat er mir Antibiotika verschrieben.
Also mir geht es immer noch nicht gut, muss ich sagen.
Aber habe seit heute Morgen auch so einen Ausschlag überall am Körper bekommen.
Und dann hat er gesagt, er hat auch nochmal Blut abgenommen und gesagt, ich müsste ins Krankenhaus gehen.
Das sind die Hauptprobleme, die ich habe.
Sie haben heute Hals-Ausschlag bekommen.
Hals-Ausschlag, ja.
Wo ist Ihre Hals-Ausschlag?
Am ganzen Körper.
Am ganz?
Ja, überall.
Arme, Beine, Brum, Brücken.
Jucktes?
Ist ein bisschen juckend, ja.
Ist es Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie auch Schwellungen anheißen oder Schluckstören oder Atemnot haben?
Atemnot nicht, aber beim Schlucken habe ich Schmerzen, weil die Mandeln sind immer noch sehr stark geschwollt und renzündet.
Und Lymphknoten hier habe ich auch noch, die tun auch weh.
Ein bisschen Bauchschmerzen habe ich auch, muss ich jetzt auch so sagen.
Und das Fieber ist jetzt nicht mehr ganz so hoch.
Also ich habe jetzt nur noch so knapp 38, aber es war mal höher, war fast 40 Grad des Fieber.
War mal e.V. 40 Grad?
Ja, so ungefähr ein Mittwoch, so ungefähr ein Mittwoch, soll erst sagen, muss gewesen sein, ja.
Prost haben Sie Antibiotika eingenommen haben?
Ja, dann war ich zwei Tage so zu Hause und dann bin ich am Freitag zum Haushaltsgegen, hat mir Antibiotika aufgeschrieben.
Nach der Antibiotika war ihr Fieber immer noch hoch?
Ja, also ist heute auch noch ein bisschen, also wie schon sagte so ungefähr 38.
38.
Ist es Ihnen aufgefallen, dass nach der Antibiotistherapie ihr Lymphknoten oder Halsschmerzen verbessern hat?
Nein, kann ich nicht sagen, es ist immer noch stark geschmessen.
Die Lymphknoten sind immer noch dick hier am Hals.
Also und Bauchschmerzen habe ich auch jetzt bekommen.
Sie haben mir erwähnt, dass ihr in Haushalts-Test gemacht und ihnen geschickt habe.
Was für ein Test war es, Bluttest oder hat er etwas gesagt?
Also er hat Bluttest gemacht, hat gesagt, ich muss ins Kragen rausgehen, ja.
Nach dem Bluttest?
Ja, ja.
Also habe ich heute erfahren, nachdem ich gesagt habe, ich habe auch Schlag,
dann war ich bei ihm kurz, ich muss ins Kragen rausgehen,
da er die Ergebnisse zum Blutbild gab.
Man hat mir jetzt nichts genaues gesagt, ich weiß nicht genau, was da nicht normal ist.
Ja, hat er nicht genannt, okay.
Nein.
Können Sie mir sagen, dass es einen Auslöser gab für diese Halsschlag?
Also ich meine, nachdem die Antibiotika genommen habe, ist es dann aufgetreten.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es irgendwie damit zusammenhängt.
Aber es war am 5.Tag.
Ja.
Am 3.Tag hatten Sie keine Auslöcher?
Nein.
Erst nachdem ich Antibiotika bekommen habe, habe ich am Samstag genommen,
Samstag Sonntag und heute, ja, am 3.Tag habe ich bekommen.
Am 3.Tag.
Vielleicht hat es gestern angefangen, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht am 2.Tag.
Ungefähr.
Hat es Sie früher in der Antibiotika oder irgendeinem Medikament?
Kann ich mich nicht erinnern? Nein.
Wann haben Sie das ausprobiert für diese Halsschlag?
Nein.
Antihistaminika, allergie-Tabletin?
Nein, ich nehme nur wegen Fieber und Schmerz,
ich nehme pro Tag 3 Ibuprofen.
3 Stück am Tag, nehmen Sie.
Wie viel Milligramm?
600 Milligramm.
Es hat Ihnen aber nicht ganz geholfen.
Nur ein bisschen.
Schmerzen Sie ein bisschen besser, aber nicht weg.
Und Fieber ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen weniger,
aber nicht ganz weg.
Okay.
Hatten Sie weitere Allergie?
Was meinen Sie mit Allergie?
Gegen-Medikamente?
Nein, ist nichts bekannt.
Oder Unverträglichkeit?
Gegen-Medikamente haben Sie?
Kann ich nichts sagen.
Nein.
Frau Bostler, leider sind Sie nicht in der Krankung?
Ich habe keine Krankheiten.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ich bin als Kind mal am Blinddarm operiert worden.
Wie abfahren Sie damals?
Sieben Jahre.
Wurden Sie schon einmal stationär behandelt?
Nur das eine Mal bei der Blinddarm.
Sonst nicht?
Sie sind in letzter Zeit in der Krankung.
Ich habe nicht mehr.
Sie sind in letzter Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Nein.
Sind Sie geimpft?
Ich bin zweimal geimpft.
Sie haben es zweimal geimpft?
Haben Sie Geruch oder Geschmack verlust?
Nein.
Also der Haushalt hat auch Corona-Tests gemacht, war negativ?
Es war negativ.
Wann hat der Haushalt dann Test gemacht?
Es war Donnerstag-Friday.
Es war Freitag.
Waren Sie geimpft?
Gelegenlich.
Nicht regelmäßig, nur wenn ich mit Freunden zusammen bin.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Auch so, nur in Gelegenheit.
Wenn ich in Gesellschaft bin.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit den Rogen?
Ja, ab und zu.
Wenn wir auf Astatis, dann nehmen wir schon ein paar Bogen ein.
Also meist Exzessipelmen oder so was.
Was sind Sie von der Hof?
Ich studiere.
Ich bin Student Volkswirtschafts-Nr.
Was studieren Sie?
Volkswirtschaft.
VWL.
Leben Sie alleine?
Ja, ich bin Ständenwohnerin.
Leben Sie hier altern noch?
Ja.
Sind Sie gesund oder leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Eigentlich sind Sie so weit gesund.
Also keine Beankrankheiten.
Nein.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, die sind auch so weit gesund.
Sie sind auch gesund.
Herr Buster, ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen.
Haben Sie noch Fragen an mich?
Eigentlich nicht.
Meinen Sie, ich muss im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Was denken Sie?
Können Sie wieder nach Hause gehen?
Ja, das kann ich Ihnen momentan nicht sagen.
Ich muss noch ein paar Fragen über die Frage stellen.
Ich möchte, ob wir uns vorlegen können,
was Ihnen zu tun ist.
Okay.
Vielleicht können Sie mir noch mal ein anderes Medikament geben
für meine Bauchschmerzen.
Das wäre vielleicht ganz gut.
Sie haben auch Bauchschmerzen.
Es tut mir leid, ich habe das nicht verstanden.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Bauchschmerzen?
Seit zwei Tagen.
Mit dem Hothouse haben Sie diese Bauchschmerzen auch.
Vielleicht etwas früher.
Ein, zwei Tage früher, glaube ich.
Haben Sie auch Übelkeit?
Erbrechen muss ich aber übel.
Übelkeit habe ich.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Seitdem ich diese kranken Fieber habe, ist es sehr schlecht.
Ansonsten war der Appetit immer gut.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der nächsten Zeit abgenommen?
Nein.
Das ist eine Woche, weiß ich nicht, ob ich abgenommen habe.
Ich glaube, er hat nichts.
Ich habe das Problem mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wassalassum.
Kann ich nicht sagen, nein.
Ist es Ihnen aufgefallen, dass die Farbe ihres Stuhl oder die Übrings sich verändert hat?
Kann ich nicht sagen, nein, war normal.
Alles war normal.
Können Sie mir bitte general zeigen, wo General-Irishmersen sind, am Bauch?
Das ist eher links oben, würde ich sagen.
Links oben.
Links am Bauch, wo ich oben bin.
Und in den Rippen, vielleicht so.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Sind Sie auf einer Schmerzgelefinance gesehen?
Die Bauchschmerzen meinen Sie?
Ja.
Drei, vier.
Okay.
Haben Sie Abgeschlagenheit?
Ja, ich habe nicht sehr spacht, seitdem ich das Fieber und die Krankheit habe.
Ja.
Gut.
Okay, sind Sie fertig mit der Annamnese?
Ja, was will ich noch fragen?
Ich habe noch eine Gruppe, ob jemand noch Ideas hat.
Ich gehe mal in den Chat rein.
Einmal hat jemand gefragt, wie heißt das Antibiotico, was Sie genommen haben.
Das heißt Amoxicillin.
Wie können Sie Ihre Bauchschmerzen beschreiben?
Haben wir gesagt, im linken Oberbauch eher dumpf.
So, Druckgefühl im Bauch.
Und dann geht es weiter.
Gelbsucht, ich hatte da nicht gehabt.
Hat jemand solche Beschwerden zu Hause oder ihrem Umfeld?
Ist ihm nicht auf, weiß er nicht.
Fühlen Sie sich schlapp?
Ja, kennen Sie diese Art von Müdigkeit?
Ist etwas Neues?
Neu, hat er vorher nicht gehabt.
Drehmensregelmäßig Sport?
Ja, macht Sport, macht Sport.
Spielt, keine Ahnung, badminton regelmäßig.
Haben Sie Gliederschmerzen?
Ja, das war ein Test, das Ergebnis war negativ.
Haben Sie für Bauchschmerzen Medikamente benutzt?
Keine besonderen.
Hier steht schon eine Diagnosefrage.
Gut, weitere Fragen oder Kommentare?
Ich habe sie gesehen.
Keine Gabsucht.
Sonst wichtige Fragen.
Haben Sie Aften im Mund?
Hat er nicht.
Was kann man noch fragen?
Wir können noch fragen, ob das Lymphknoten woanders noch hat.
Ob im Hals oder woanders.
Lymphknoten bemerkt hat es.
Ich habe sie untersucht.
Ausdann hat sie gefragt.
Das war nicht der Patient.
So war ich erinnern.
Keine Ausdannsaufenthalt in den letzten Jahren.
Gut.
Dann haben wir die wichtigsten Fragen gestellt.
Es ist ein junger Mann.
Da gibt es nicht so viel zu fragen.
Es gibt keine Medikamente.
Es gibt keine chronischen Krankheiten.
Dann stellen Sie den Patienten mal den Obarass vor.
Guten Tag Herr Obarass.
Ich habe gerade eben eine Patientin abgenommen.
Ich würde gerne die Patientin in der Frucht stellen.
Dann die Patientin in der Frucht stellen.
Danke.
Mario Pizar ist ein 24-jähriger Patientin.
Er hat die
Er hat ihm keine richtige Verbesserung gebracht.
Das hat ihre Beschwerden ein bisschen vermindert,
aber keine richtige Verbesserung hat er gehabt.
Er hat seine Bauchsmärzchen am Schmaskal mit fünf
und mit vier und fünf bewertet.
Seine Schmasten sind am linken Oberbau.
Die Frage nach Iktarus verneint.
Er hat die Patientin von der Schmerz,
Erbrech, Vomitus und Neusea.
Keine Allergie sind bei der Patientin bekannt.
Als die Patientin hat keine Kronischerkrankungen,
hat sie eine Corona-Bereichheit.
Er hat die Patientin von der Schmerz,
die sie in der Corona-Bereichheit gemacht hat.
Das hat auch der Corona Test durchgeführt und es war negativ.
Die Frage ist, ob er Trinkt-Alkohol und Raus zur Bechtung sind,
ob er eine exzessive Pilze hat.
Und fast noch, da ist der Patient ein Student
und es gibt keine wichtigen Krankheiten in seiner Familie,
habe ich etwas vergessen zu sagen?
Das waren die wichtigsten.
Die anamnistischen...
Halsschmerzen, viele haben es alles gesagt, oder?
Am Anfang, habe ich gesagt.
Okay, was denken Sie, was der Patient hat?
Ja, die anamnistischen Anfangen beachten auf ein Epstein-Barbirus,
Infektionsmononiklööses.
Aber als Haltasselab, vielleicht Milchspetächer,
Idiopathik, Trombus-Petächer...
Das war ein kleines Epstein-Barb.
Das war ein spezielles Epstein-Thema.
Am Ende des Arztes war es ein Mittel-Extran-Thema.
Ja, warum denken Sie, dass ein Epstein-Barbirus Infektion war?
Weil der Patient hat keine Antibiosetherapie.
Er hat immer noch geschwollene Lymphknoten,
nach der Antibiosetherapie.
Deswegen habe ich Epstein-Barbirus Infektionsmononikliöses gesagt.
Was spricht noch für Epstein-Barb aus den anamnistischen Angaben?
Ja, er ist ledig und sein Lebensstil, das mich auch Epstein-Barbis denken.
Er könnte natürlich auch eine andere Form der Ponzylitis haben.
Ja.
Wo Amoxiziditie nicht hilft, gibt es ja manchmal.
Kann auch sein, oder?
Ja, kann auch sein.
Wie ist das, wenn Sie ein Patient mit Epstein-Barbirus haben,
der irgendwelche Infektionen hat?
Geben Sie ihm dann Antibiotika-Amoxicinin zum Beispiel?
Amoxin hilft nicht bei Epstein-Barb-Virus.
Ja, das hilft nicht.
Klar, aber was ist das Problem?
Wir haben es immer so gelernt als Klassiker, man darf ein Patient mit Epstein-Barbius
nie Amoxicinin geben, weil sie immer Ausstark bekommen.
Kennen Sie das?
Ja, für nicht gesehen.
Es ist immer so, dass man, wenn man Verdacht auf Mononucleose hat,
man den Patienten nicht Amoxicin geben sollte, kontraindiziert,
haben wir mal so gelernt.
Wenn er irgendwelche anderen Infektionen hat,
dann kann man das nicht mehr an das Antibiotikum geben.
Wir haben das nur bei Amoxicinin, die sind bei anderen nicht,
weiß ich nicht, aber das ist ein Hinweis,
dass es eine EBV-Infektion sein kann,
dass er auf Amoxicin eine Reaktion gehabt hat.
Also, Amoxicin kann auch ohne EBV zu Ausschlag führen.
Aber bei EBV ist es so der Klassiker, dass das zum Exantemen führen kann.
Gut, dass du bist.
Ich wusste das früher nicht.
Ja, aus Pirin auch.
Ich guck grad mal in den Chat, was wir noch alles gefragt haben.
Bei einigen Vireninfektionen sehen wir mit Amoxicin-Trac-Eruption,
zum Beispiel Asymethylmucleicinose.
Der Gegengegen-Penicinin kann sein,
aber man muss nicht.
Schala ist auch eine Differenzialdiagnose, richtig.
Amoxicin für Zautauschlag, Aspirin auch.
Aspirin weiß ich nicht.
Genau, und jetzt die Bauchbeschwerden.
Man muss auf Mitstruktur achten.
Das wäre eine wichtige Information,
die auch auf eine EBV-Infektion hindeutet,
diese Schmerzen im Bereich Linken Oberbau.
Was ist das Problem?
Was passiert da bei EBV?
Warum haben die Schmerzen Schmerzen im Linken Oberbau?
Genau, das haben Sie auch richtig im Chat gesagt.
Dann muss man aufpassen,
gerade bei der Milsunterverpackung,
bei Patio nicht, dass die Mils rupturiert.
Dann muss man vorsichtig sein, Belastung vermeiden.
Wie behandeln Sie den Patienten?
Oder wie stellen Sie die Diagnose?
Das ist ja nur eine Verdachtdiagnose,
kann auch was anderes sein.
Wie stellen Sie die Diagnose?
Das ist eine weitere Abklärung.
Zuerst dann die Patientin Körperleutung.
Körperleutung muss sich dann abtesten
und organomegaly bestimmen oder überprüfen,
ob der Patient hepatsomegaly oder splinomegaly hat.
Und das vorsichtig,
weil das splinomegaly vorsichtig tastet.
Bei Mils rüptur oder kann passieren?
Genau.
Ich würde gerne unbedingt Blutbild sehen.
Warum?
Bei Mils rüptur oder trombostopeni
oder trombostopeni hat.
Das ist eine Infektion.
Ich würde gerne nicht so viele Lokostosalzen sehen.
Sie haben Blutbild gemacht,
ein machineres Blutbild,
da hat eine Leukocytose.
Ist das sicher?
Oder eine Leukocytose hilft Ihnen das weiter?
Wenn Sie das wissen,
dass eine Leukocytose hat von 17.000.
Leukostose 17.000.
Ist das dann ausreicht das aus als Ergebnis?
Oder wo nachfragen Sie noch?
Es kann sein,
dass er gleichzeitig andere Infektionen hat.
Kann sein, ja.
Aber wo nachfragen Sie,
wenn Sie ein Blutbild ins Labor als Auftakt geben,
was wollen Sie noch hören von dem?
Reicht Ihnen die Leukocytenzahl?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Sie haben es ja schon gesagt,
Sie wollen ein Differenzialblutbild haben.
Was heißt denn Differenzial?
Was wollen Sie denn differenzieren?
Warum heißt das Differenzialblutbild?
Passtopeni.
Kann sein, aber es ist nicht immer so.
Es gibt auch mal EWV mit Passtopeni.
Meistens ist bei der EWV-Infektion auch Kropozytendormal.
Also es müsste nicht niedrig sein.
Oder Hemoglobin muss auch nicht niedrig sein.
Kann.
Aber in der Regel ist es dann nur eine.
Aber Sie machen ja
ein Differenzialblutbild.
Bekommen Sie die Ergebnisse erstmal maschinell
über die Untergruppen der Leukocytenten?
Ja.
Welche Untergruppen kennen Sie denn,
die wichtig sind bei den?
Was ist denn das Wichtigste?
Das ist bei Epstein-Bar das Wichtigste.
Bei Epstein-Bar monostosien.
Monostosien oder Lymphozytose auch oft.
Also Sie sehen praktisch bei den Leukocytenten
den größten Anteil nicht an Neutrophilen.
Also nicht Grammlozyten sind erhöht.
Was ja oft schon der Bakterienfektion sprechen wird.
Sondern die Leukocytenten sind nicht so viel.
Wenn Sie das Maschinell haben, also Sie haben ein Ergebnis,
reicht das schon aus.
Man reicht auch nicht aus, weil wenn die Leukocytenten erhöht
sein sollten, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel
Gesamtleukocytenten mal ein bisschen erfunden 40.000 Leukocytenten
und davon 39.000 Leukocytenten.
Was kann es auch noch sein?
Ja, wir müssen bestimmen, ob diese Leukocytenten
nicht mehr so viel sind.
Das ist ja auch ein Problem.
Wir müssen bestimmen, ob diese Leukocytenten
wegen Neutrophil oder
Farmartinotrophilen oder Farmartinotrophilen zum Beispiel
sind.
Genau.
Jetzt haben Sie gemacht, Neutrophilen sind 1%
und Lymphocytenten über 90%.
Also Sie haben ungefähr 30.000 Lymphocytenten
im Bärreferndblut. Was kann das noch sein?
Eine wichtige Differenzialdiagnose bei eBV-Infektionen.
Was kann das noch sein von der Krankheit?
Leukocytenten erhöht.
Hallo Chemie, ja.
Ja, Leukomie kann sein, das ist eine wichtige Differenzialdiagnose.
Wenn Sie das Differenzialblutbild haben,
Maschinell, also Sie haben die Zahlen, was machen Sie dann noch?
Haben die Kollegen auch schon geschrieben, das ist wichtig,
wenn man die Zellen mal anguckt und dann Mikroskop,
nennt man Blutausstrich,
dann gucken Sie nach dem, wie die Zellen aussehen,
weil manchmal zählt die Maschine falsch,
die zählt die Lymphocytenten bei der Monocytenten
und so weiter, dann müssen Sie sich angucken
und wenn Sie da typische Zellen haben, so Reizform,
dann haben Sie auch Hinweis auf die Diagnose.
Wenn es zum Beispiel sehr viele Blastherezellen da sind,
dann sind die Zellen nicht bei ebv,
aber es könnte Hinweis auf Leukomie sein.
Also Differenzialblutbild,
dann gibt es nur, wenn man es nicht ganz genau weiß,
manchmal ist es nicht klar, es ist nicht so einfach,
manchmal ist es zu unterscheiden von Leukomie,
was kann man noch machen?
Haben die Kollegen glaube ich schon ein Chat geschrieben,
was kann man noch für Tests machen,
um zu sichern, dass es Smallbis Pfeiffer oder Monocleose ist?
Antikörper haben Sie geschrieben.
Antikörper-Spieger.
Im Antikörper gegen bestimmte Bestandteile,
Kapitatige und so weiter.
Okay, gut.
Und wie behandeln Sie den Patienten,
wenn es ein Morbis Pfeiffer oder Monocleose oder ebv ist?
Wie behandelt man den?
Ganz einfach, ein Wort.
Symptomatisch?
Ja, genau.
Symptomatisch waren, wer gesagt so.
Gut, jetzt gucken wir mal in den Chat, ob es noch Fragen oder Kommentare gab.
So, Moment.
Genau, Blutausstrich,
Lymphocytin, Pfeiffer-Geimer, also Lymphoma,
Lymphocytose, Pfeiffer-Zellen, ja,
wenn man die erkennen kann, ist gut, Pfeiffer-Ausstrich, Leukomie,
Antikörper, celluletester, genau.
Ebv-Schnelltest gibt es auch mittlerweile, ja, genau.
Okay, gut, das waren so die wichtigsten Kommentare.
Okay, ja, Spezile gegen Kapitantigenia.
Gut, gibt es noch Fragen dazu?
Kommentare, weitere.
Aber für das erste Mal war sehr gut.
Das war die,
ich bin ein Estetist,
und das ist Hermitistin.
Keine Ahnung, gerade diese.
Das ist so losgesagt, ja.
Aber gut, so was kann auch mal ein Anesthetist treffen,
wenn er Notdienst macht, ne?
Ja.
Danke.
Buchen, Nüchbuk, jetzt hin.
Muss das in der Wand werden, ist Frage, wie Symptom lastig ist.
Wenn die Symptome nicht so stark sind, kann man auch Ambulanz lassen, ja.
Genau, sehr gute Ergebnisse von der Vorstellung, finde ich auch.
Also, alle beide haben bestanden heute, ja.
Mhm.
Da mal.
Buchen, Nüchbuk, gefällt dir dem?
Ich würde es, ich würde es auch.
Ja, ich schau mal, ich habe dich hier gelassen.